So before we do the work in our Editor, I need
to teach you another little bit of HTML.
So we've seen the value parameter on some form elements,
and let's talk about how we use it in the text element case.
This is our normal text element that we've been using.
Now, of course, this will all be familiar to you:
And this part is new--this is a value attribute,
and this causes the text box, when we render it,
to have this "cool" as the default value.
So you can see, this might be useful for rendering our form
with the values that the user just typed in--
so they don't have to keep reentering things all the time.
And you can also use this to fill out form fields
with default values, if you know what the user is probably going to enter.
Okay--so I hope you can see the direction we're heading.
We're going to populate our form s with what the user typed in.
So which of these little bits of HTML
is the correct for preserving the user's month?